-So fun last night.
-Wasn't that a blast?
-Oh, my God.
-You are the coolest ever.
-I was the coolest one
in the room.
-You were.
-No, I wasn't. I wasn't.
-Are you excited about this or
is it too much attention on you?
-I'm excited about it.
It's a weird thing.
Like, when you're up
for a Grammy or whatever,
it's like,
"Oh, that's so nice."
And then you start going,
"What if I don't win?
That's gonna be weird."
You know?
And so when I see my name
in the nominations,
I'm like, "That's so cool,
but, oh, gosh,
what if I don't get in?"
So it's a weird thing.
-This one you are winning.
You actually
are getting inducted.
-I know. I have to say, though.
So, I have two boys, and they're
16 and 13, which you know.
-Yeah.
-And right now I'm sort of --
You know, I'm sort of
on their nerves a lot
and I get a lot
of eye rolling and stuff.
But the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame?
My 13-year-old was like,
"So is that like
the Baseball Hall of Fame
or like the NBA Hall of Fame?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
And he's like...
-That's pretty cool.
-And I was like...
-"Yes! I scored!
I finally did something cool!"
-I did it! Yeah. Yeah.
-Do they -- Do they know --
I know they know you as mom.
But do they know you
as Sheryl Crow?
-They have grown up
on the tour bus.
In fact, Wyatt took
his first steps
in the green room at "Ellen."
-That's cool.
-But they don't -- I mean,
that was normal for them.
They don't really understand.
But Levi the other day
did say, "Mom, were you like
Taylor in your day?"
And I was just like,
"Oh, yeah, I was -- I was --
I was just like Taylor
in my day."
-Yeah. You were like Taylor.
Yeah.
You definitely opened the door
for Taylor, too, as well.
-Oh, that's very nice.
Oh, my God. That's so nice.
-You have a speech ready to go?
-I do.
I think it's gonna come in
right around 4.5 hours.
-[ Laughs ]
You're thanking everybody?
-Everybody I know. In fact,
I want to thank the Roots
and I want to thank you.
-Yeah. Of course. Thank us.
Thank the Roots.
Can I go through the list?
Missy Elliott,
Rage Against the Machine,
Kate Bush, the Spinners,
Willie Nelson.
You're on the same year
as Willie Nelson.
-Oh, my God. For me, that's,
like, the biggest thing.
I mean, I am so happy
to be in the Rock Hall,
and I can't believe 37 years
of being in this business
has gone by.
But I can't believe I've gotten
to sing with Willie Nelson
and I know him
and he knows his kids.
-You're friends with Willie.
-He offered my dad weed.
-No! Don't do that.
Day, say no. Just say no. Yeah.
-It was the only time --
My dad is, like, you know,
great small-town attorney.
Atticus Finch.
And so I take him
to "Crossroads,"
and Willie's, like,
offering him weed,
and he's like --
He was kind of like, "No."
And all of a sudden, I'm like,
"Whoa. Cool guy up here."
You know, I was expecting him
to throw Willie
under, like, citizen's arrest.
-Yeah.
"Don't you smoke grass!"
-That's right.
-Yeah.
-"I'm taking you to jail!"
-Yeah. But you're performing
with Olivia Rodrigo.
That's one of the surprises
in the thing.
Sorry I just ruined it.
-Surprise!
-Surprise! Act surprised.
When you're watching -- when
you're streaming tomorrow,
act surprised.
But you recently sang with
Olivia Rodrigo in Nashville.
-Yeah, at the Bluebird Cafe.
Yeah, she is --
-Real deal.
-She's the real deal.
She's precious.
She's a great songwriter.
She's --
I mean, she seems
kind of unaffected
by all of it, you know?
-She's handling it well.
-Yeah, she is.
I mean, when I was 19, her age,
I was like,
"How do you fill out
this application for college?"
You know, I mean...
-How do you do
any of this stuff?
How did you guys meet?
-I met her last year during
a whole bunch of Grammy stuff.
-Yeah.
-And we wound up
on some stuff together, and...
She's super cool.
And so she asked me
to do this thing
when she came to Nashville.
And so I was like, "Okay."
-Yeah.
-So I texted her and said,
"Hey, would you do
the Rock Hall with me?"
And she's like, "I would
love to. I'd be so honored."
-That's gonna be
an unbelievable night.
-I know.
I was cool with my kids.
-Yeah. So now you're double
cool. Now you're double cool.
-Yeah.
-Well, talk to me about this.
You have a new album coming out.
-I do.
-You're debuting
the first song...
-It's full of hits.
-...tonight.
-I'm kidding.
-It is.
-No. I said a few years ago
I'd never make another record.
-You did? You might have said it
on our show or something.
Or we discussed it because --
I go,
"Why wouldn't you
make another album?"
And you --
-I don't know.
I can't really trust
what comes out of my mouth.
-So funny. You're so funny.
Because you were like,
"I don't know if people listen
to albums anymore."
-They don't really
listen to albums,
but my philosophy about it was,
okay, I'm gonna make --
I'm gonna write songs
that are meaningful
in the moment, right?
So instead of writing
an entire book,
I'll just put out sentences
or I'll put, you know --
But I wound up
with a bunch of songs
that I'd written just recently,
starting off with "Evolution,"
which is a song about A.I.,
speaking about the Beatles.
-Yeah.
-And it's been
so disturbing to me.
I don't know how you
musicians feel about it,
but I did a session
the other day,
and this young songwriter
had this incredible song,
but she needed a guy
to sing on it
so that she could pitch it
to male singers in Nashville.
Paid $5,
put in John Mayer's name,
and she played it for me,
and my -- [Imitates explosion]
There's no way you could
tell the difference.
And it just blew my mind.
-It sounded like John Mayer?
-It sounded not just --
Didn't just sound like him.
I mean, like,
his inflections and...
And so this is what A.I. can do.
-That is scary, right?
-And it really --
it really scared me.
Only because, you know,
for me, art is like soul.
It's attached to the soul.
So when you get into something
that's so much more advanced
than our brains are
at this point,
it takes the soul out of it,
you know?
-It's kind of scary.
-It's scary.
So that's how it started.
I wrote a song called
"Evolution" about it.
I called my friend
Mike Elizondo,
which was like
calling Martin Scorsese.
And I said, "I have this song."
And, man, he created
the most incredible movie
around this song.
-He crushed it.
-He cruh-huh-hushed it!
-Yes!
-I mean, it's so amazing.
So then I was like, "Hmm.
I'm gonna do some more songs."
-Yeah, yeah, you got the bug,
and you're like,
"Come on. I'm Sheryl Crow."
-"I don't need to
produce myself.
I don't have time for that."
-Yeah. Right?
-The album's gonna come out
March 29th.
So what you're gonna do
is release a song every month?
-"Alarm Clock"
is coming out first.
-"Alarm Clock." Alright.
That's the one to stream.
-And every month,
we'll put out a different song.
-Do your boys
like "Alarm Clock"?
-They really like it.
There's one on there, though,
that's called "Broken Record,"
and they're like,
"Mom, you're not gonna put
that on your record, are you?"
And I was like,
"Yeah, yeah, I am."
They're like,
"Mom, no. Just no."
Do you ever get "Just no"?
-"Just no."
-You ever get "Just no"
from your kids? "Just no."
-My kids are 10 and 8.
They still love me.
-They do?
-Yeah.
-Oh, that's gonna change.
-It's gonna change.
-That's gonna change.
-Yeah. But that's pretty --
And they're coming out.
The whole family's coming out.
-Yeah, and they are actually.
They're awesome. I'm so blessed.
-Yeah. Congrats. It couldn't
happen to a better person.
You're in the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame.
Next time you're here,
you're gonna be ind-- Yeah!
That's exactly right!
The best!
Sheryl Crow, everybody!
You can live-stream the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame induction
on Disney+.
And "Evolution"
will be out next year.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show." Stick around!